the crunch too much too little too fat
too thin or nobody laughter or tears
haters lovers strangers with faces like
the backs of thumbtacks armies running
through streets of blood waving wine
bottles bayoneting and [ __ ] virgins
or an old guy in a cheap room with a
photograph of em Monroe there is a
loneliness in this world so great that
you can see it in a slow movement of the
hands of a clock people so tired
mutilated either by love or no love
people are just not good to each other
one on one the rich are not good to the
rich the poor are not good to the poor
we are afraid our educational system
tells us that we can all be big ass
winners it hasn't told us about the
gutters or the suicides or the terror of
one person aching in one place alone
untouched unspoken to watering a plant
people are not good to each other people
are not good to each other
people are not good to each other
I suppose they never will be I didn't
ask them to be but sometimes I think
about it the beads will swing the clouds
will cloud and the killer will behead
the child by taking a bite out of an
ice-cream car too much too little too
fat too thin or nobody more haters than
lovers people are not good to each other
perhaps if they were our deaths would
not be so sad meanwhile I look at young
girls stems flowers of chance there must
be a way surely there must be a way we
have not yet thought of it who put this
brain inside of me it cries it demands
it says there is a chance it will not
say no
[Music]
you